- Hi, I'm Kirk Adkins.
Welcome to my shop.
I'm a horseshoer by trade.
Graduated from high school,
bought a new pickup truck
in 1971
and I've been shoeing horses
full-time
or part-time ever since.
I started making my own blades
back about 25 years ago
because I had
carpal tunnel syndrome
and it was really hard on
my hands with the hoof knives.
So I designed a better
hoof knife for myself
and I make a little business
out of it,
selling it to other farriers.
I do quite a bit of woodworking
because of the handle-making
for my knives.
So I have the band saw
and the table saw
that I set up for the blanks.
But right here
is the heart and soul
of my horseshoe company.
It's 125-ton
hydraulic punch press.
And this thing
can really smash some stuff.
- Well, I can tell you about
the history of, like,
almost mankind
through horseshoes.
[laughs]
The shoe I'm gonna make is
called a caulk and wedge.
It has a little bit
of a thickened toe
and it has two cleats
on the heels.
Okay, a quick pack in the toe.
These shoes were designed to be
used in the cobblestone streets
of England
and through the muddy trails.
All right, we got the inside
heels done.
That heel is called a wedge,
so that's the caulk
and the wedge--
that's the wedge part
of the name.
So I'm gonna move on
to the outside heel.
Aw, scale in my coffee.
- Up over my left shoulder,
that's my draft horse shoe
that I designed
and now fabricating for
the California Highway Patrol.
I use steel
and other kinds of metals
and I combine them with
21st-century polymers
into a contiguous unit.
It's a really beneficial
system for horses
that have to work
on hard surfaces like that.
The thing that's cool about
horseshoeing is,
I have my foot in
the 11th century,
when the first horses
were shod,
and the 21st century with
the new polymers and plastics
and I combine them
into a new technology
and it's just a real
satisfying thing
to be able to go
all the way in that--
from ancient to modern and
still be doing the same job.
- All right,
we're gonna do a toe bend.
[upbeat music]
♪ ♪
What I just started
is called the fullering,
or the crease of the shoe.
It's gonna give me a spot
to pit my nailheads
and it's gonna be a trough,
continuing down
throughout the shoe.
Go ahead and mark
some nail holes out.
♪ ♪
Give her a ding.
You'll notice
this shoe isn't symmetrical.
It's 'cause horses' feet
aren't symmetrical.
Horses have lefts and rights,
just like we do.
All right, do a quick shape up.
♪ ♪
What I'm drawing out now
is called the clip.
It's gonna be married
into the hoof wall,
so it'll be one with the foot
and it conjoins the hoof
and the shoe really well
and it takes all the stress
off the nails.
That's how you make
a little 3/4 fuller
caulk and wedge horseshoe.
♪ ♪
- I, uh, was fortunate enough
to buy this.
It is an 1873 Trenton
175-pound farrier's anvil.
It will be passed on
to some worthy person
sometime after my passing,
but it is an awesome
piece of equipment
and I'm happy to have it.
This is my forge.
Just relined it.
It's all in good shape.
Tubing bender.
I have my clamp rack
for all of my laminations.
I do a lot of laminating
of special hardwoods
for the knights and things.
And, uh, boxes of things
that I find valuable.
You know, people have things
that you can't get rid of.
So anyway...
Here we are.
This is where it happens.